[Musique]
chantal retourne chez elle en autobus sa
valise et dans la soute à bagages au
moment de la récupérer alone bien
mauvaise surprise
la valise et disparus le chauffeur la
remise par erreur à une autre passagère
à l'arrêt précédent
il lui dit qu'il ne put rien faire mais
il prend en note son numéro de téléphone
quelques jours plus tard un préposé de
l'entreprise l'appel
la passagère qui était parti avec sa
valise s'est manifesté mais l'entreprise
ne veut pas un des chantal elle lui dit
que c'est à elle de se débrouiller pour
contacter la dame et faire livrer sa
valise quand chantal récupère enfin sa
valise au terminus l'entreprise exige 22
dollars pour le transport
chantal doit elle payer cette somme non
parce que c'est le chauffeur qui a
commis une erreur en remettant sa valise
à la mauvaise personne
l'entreprise est responsable de la forme
de son chauffeur elle aurait donc dû
être plus diligente envers chantal le
mot de l'histoire
si votre valise est perdu par la faute
de l'entreprise
ne vous laissez pas charrier elle doit
vous dédommager